to the united states now today's primary
election in wyoming are being seen as a
test of how important an endorsement
from former president donald trump is
for republican voters this ahead of
november's crucial midterm elections
wyoming has become a political
battlefield republican harriet hageman
who's endorsed by donald trump is
challenging republican incumbent liz
cheney cheney played a leading role in
the congressional committee
investigating the january 6 attack on
the capitol
and dw's enis poole joins us now from
wyoming state capital cheyenne the enis
tell us more about these two candidates
hageman and cheney
yeah alice cheney is really republican
royalty her father dick cheney was the
vice president
with uh george w bush he has been in
politics kind of forever so has she she
has been the congressman woman of
wyoming since
2019 and really raised quickly to the
top uh
in the republican hierarchy she was
number three
in the party before she was the one of
the first republicans actually who
really condemned president trump's
involvement in the six of uh january
riots and that as we know uh turned
trump against her and then he
uh supported harriet hageman she used to
be an attorney in her own law firm here
uh in the state's capital in cheyenne
she was actually really close friends
with liz jenny they kind of shared the
same very conservative political views
they called each other friends before
donald trump endorsed her to run against
liz cheney on today's primary
so those are the candidates let's take a
look now at the state they want to
represent and then come back to you
wyoming is known for its bisons cowboys
and
never-ending skies
it is the least populated state and
politically deep red 70
voted for donald trump in the last
election
the western state has hardly ever been
in the focus of political attention but
that has changed dramatically wyoming is
now a key political battlefield because
of the fight within the republican party
this cheney is enemy number one for
trump loyalists ever since she became
one of the first republicans to condemn
the former president for his involvement
in the storming of the capital on
january 6. we meet voters in a downtown
coffee shop in the state's capital
cheyenne to understand the division what
this means for the gop in wyoming if we
go down this road
is it becomes a party of extremists and
we can't count on extremists to make
solid policy we really don't like that
wyoming really voted heavily for trump
and then she takes this path where she
denies trump due process i think that's
where america is we're at a point now
where
we have to vote for people and the
character that they are and vote for
their integrity
and let the policies work themselves out
the way they always have
at stake in this election the battle
between democratic institutions and the
profound influence that president trump
and his supporters still have among
republicans
all right so we have a bit of an
overview enos what do the polls say it's
not expected to be a close race is it
no not at all uh
hageman is like 29 or so points ahead of
liz cheney so many many voters obviously
made up their minds and we just read
polls that even if any democrat and any
independent would vote for liz cheney
she wouldn't be able to win this race so
this is a clear cut why is that because
of donald trump and therefore this
election is so crucial in the whole
united states actually is really
watching it because it will prove
whoever donald trump adores
endorses uh it will win this election
and nicole you know it's also important
to know that
seven of the ten republicans who turned
their back towards uh donald trump uh uh
and voted to uh invictan is they they
lost their seeds or actually uh
left uh politics because he is still so
powerful within the gop and this will be
the result tonight it's not even so his
name isn't in the in the ballot here
it's not mainly about liz cheney or
harry hagman it really is about the
question how strong how strong is donald
trump still within the republican party
enos paul thank you so much
you